Der 1. FC Köln steht trotz einer deftigen 0 zu 3 Niederlage in Magdeburg weiter auf Platz 1 der 2. Bundesliga und will zurück ins Oberhaus. Der 1. FC Nürnberg hingegen schleicht sich so unbeirrt von internen Querelen mit zuletzt drei Siegungen allmählich an die Aufstiegsplätze heran, gehen der FC und der Club am Ende sogar zusammen hoch. Das bespreche ich nun mit Fadi Kiblavi von den Nürnberger Nachrichten und Dennis Vom Trotzdem hier Podcast.
Let's go.
Jetzt nun im Programm.
Der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Russies zu kurz Abwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das an's Turno.
Markus Kurt aus dem Bivou.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Und damit herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe der Liga Tour. Genauer genommen die der zweiten Bundesliga der Männer. Mein Name ist Marc Schuizki. Ich bin freier Sportjournalist. Man kennt mich vor allem von RBB und von Hertha Base. Und ich führe heute endlich mal wieder durch die Sendung. Zuletzt hat ja Eva das gefühlt am Stück getan. So war das nicht gedacht. Aber Krankheit und Termine und was auch immer Leben passiert. Aber endlich bin ich wieder dabei und ich bin nicht alleine. Ich habe zwei wunderbare Gäste dabei. Zum einen er schreibt für die Nürnberger Nachrichten und spricht im K-Dep-Podcast über den Club. Grüß dich Fadi. Hi.
Schönen guten Abend aus Nürnberg. Hallo.
Hallo. Und zum anderen FC-Fan, stolz er jetzt im Moment nicht, Schieber, Mützenträger und Co-Host des Trotz hier Podcasts Dennis. Grüß dich.
Hallo und danke, dass ich da sein darf.
Na aber. Ansonsten bleiben wir, bevor wir ins Inhaltliche gehen, nur noch zu sagen, sprecht es mir nach. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe-, Paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Er finanziert sich allein durch die Spenden der HörerInnen, beispielsweise U Hoeneß, Jan, der KSJ-Fans 2001, Herr Tlinio, Stadionfahrer 1898 und 1905, Tim, bei denen wir uns allesamt bedanken wollen. Die Spenden finanzieren nicht nur den Lebensunterhalt von Max, sondern ermöglichen auch, dass die Gäste ein Honorar bekommen und dass Menschen wie ich und Eva den Podcast ebenfalls moderieren können und Max dadurch entlasten können. Wenn ihr das also unterstützen wollt, dann schaut auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclubvorbei. Und wir haben keine Zeit zu verlieren. Wir gehen direkt in die Lage der Liga und besprechen, was es denn an diesem mal wieder ja bunten Zweitligaspieltag gegeben hat. Und ich fall mit der Tür ins Haus. Wir haben eine ganz konkrete Personalien natürlich zu besprechen, was auch in meinen, ich sag mal, Expertisegebiet fällt. Aber ich möchte euch natürlich da auch einbinden. Christian Fjell. Ja, viele Niederlagen besiegeln das aus, auch wenn die Leistung gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf beim der 1 zu 2 Niederlage absolut in Ordnung ging. Christian Fjell musste nach rund acht Monaten seine Zelte jetzt in Berlin abbrechen. Und damit gibt es auch schon einen neuen Trainer, Stefan Leitel. Über den sprechen wir gleich. Erst mal Christian Fjell. Fadi, ich hol dich da mal mit ins Boot. Denn ich hab ja jetzt Christian Fjell über acht Monate sehr intensiv verfolgen können. Und am Ende des Tages muss man eben sagen, Christian Fjell ist der Prediger von schönem Fußball, predigt aber von dem gelobten Land, was er gefühlt selbst noch nie betreten hat. Also so wirklich Erfolge kann er in seiner Trainer-Vita, die ja noch kurz ist, das muss man fairerweise sagen, noch nicht wirklich vorweisen. Und auch bei Hertha war es so, dass seine taktischen Ideen, die wirklich sehr mutig und dominant daherkommen, sehr selten über Ansätze hinausgekommen sind. Hertha war nicht zwingend, offensiv oft harmlos und defensiv immer mal wieder unkonzentriert. Hast du das in seiner Nürnberger Zeit genauso wahrgenommen?
Ja, zumindest als er für die erste Mannschaft verantwortlich war. Er ist ja nach Nürnberg gekommen als Trainer der zweiten Mannschaft, was ein durchaus überraschender Schritt war, weil er ja auch schon Profifußball hinter sich hatte als Trainer und dann in die Regionalliga Bayern geht. Und da hat er sich eigentlich in Nürnberg einen relativ guten Namen gemacht, tatsächlich mit dem schönen Spiel, das da auch erfolgreich war in der zweiten Mannschaft, ist dann irgendwann befördert worden und hat auch in Nürnberg dafür gesorgt, dass die Menschen wieder Lust auf den Club bekommen haben, hat zu Beginn der vergangenen Saison wirklich schönen und auch teilweise erfolgreichen Fußball spielen lassen. Irgendwann ist es ihm dann entglitten und man hatte so ein bisschen den Eindruck in Nürnberg, er hat nicht mehr den Plan B. Trotzdem hätten die Verantwortlichen mit ihm weitergemacht in Nürnberg. Ich glaube, er war einfach nach einem Jahr 1. FC Nürnberg allein verantwortlich für die 1. Mannschaft zermürbt, was rund um diesen Verein und in diesem Verein immer wieder los ist. Vielleicht ist das auch ein bisschen auch eine Palerile zur Hertha. Also da es auch in Nürnberg gab es verschiedene Gruppen, die mehr gegeneinander als miteinander gearbeitet haben. Und ich glaube darüber hat Christian Fjeld dann die Lust verloren und dachte es sich dann cool, gehe ich zu Hertha und spiel da richtig geilen Fußball. Hat jetzt leider auch nicht geklappt.
Hat leider auch nicht geklappt. Das Ergebnis mal kurz in Zahlen ausgedrückt. 25 Punkte nach 22 Spielen, 2 Siege und nur 13 Tore aus den letzten 12 Spielen. Und jetzt eben 4 Niederlagen in Serie und damit nur noch 5 Zähler Abstand auf den Religationsplatz 16. Und damit sind die Berliner ganz offiziell im Abschließkampf der 2. Bundesliga angekommen. So anders kann man es nicht sagen. Auch wenn ich sagen möchte, ich könnte hier stundenlang reden. Und ich verweise jetzt mal schamlos auch auf den Hertha-Base-Podcast, wo wir das natürlich in anderthalb bis zwei Stunden auseinandergenommen haben und in den letzten Wochen immer wieder darüber gesprochen haben. Aber Christian Fjell ist am Ende auch nur ein Symptom eines Vereins, bei dem die Probleme tiefer liegen. Ja, Hertha hat durch den Berliner Weg und Kai Berndschein und auch durch den neuen Präsidenten Fabian Drescher eine Einigkeit, die es seit Jahren, vielleicht Jahrzehnten nicht mehr gab bei Hertha BSC. Und trotzdem muss man sagen, dass dieser Verein heruntergewirtschaftet ist und heruntergerockt, was Kompetenz im Verein angeht. Also wir müssen über Scouting reden, über Datenanalyse, über Physiose, Athletik, alles Mögliche. Und eben auch über den Trainerstab, den Christian Fjell zur Seite gestellt bekommen hat. Der durfte damals nicht Jerome Polenz aus Nürnberg mitbringen, weil Hertha dafür eigentlich U19-Trainer Oliver Reis vorgesehen hatte. Der fühlte sich davon aber so wenig wertgeschätzt, dass er den Verein in kurzer Hand verlassen hat und in die Jugend zu Manchester City gegangen ist. Und so hat sich dann ein Trainerstab zusammengefunden, der noch grüner hinter den Ohren war als Christian Fjell selbst. Das hat man versucht zu korrigieren mit Armin Reutershahn im Winter, der aber auch da erst nach dem Wintertrainingslager kam. Also auch da war der Wirkungsbereich klein. Man hat Christian Fjell nicht die Spieler an die Hand gegeben, auch wenn der Kader überdurchschnittlich talentiert ist, die er für sein Spiel braucht. Allen voran der Stoßstimme hat gefehlt. Man hat im Winter dann auch niemanden nachverpflichtet. Nachverpflichten können, weil das Geld fehlte. Dieses Geld steckt ja aber auch in bereits bestehenden Transferflops. Andrés Bucalake, Smile Prevlerk und so weiter, die man nicht los wird. Also will sagen, ich glaube, dass in Berlin allen bewusst ist, dass man nicht einfach nur die Trainerpersonalien tauscht und dann wird man in besagtes gelobtes Land geführt. Die Probleme liegen tiefer und die muss man spätestens im Sommer ganz ehrlich angehen. Jetzt aber übernimmt Stefan Leitel, ein alter Bekannter der zweiten Bundesliga. Wir kennen ihn aus Fürth, wir kennen ihn zuletzt aus Hannover. Es wurde heute auf der PK, Antrittspk oft zitiert. Es ist erst sieben Wochen her, dass er noch bei 96 an der Seitenlinie stand. Das tut er jetzt nicht mehr. Er soll es bis 2027 bei Hertha BSC tun. Ein durchaus beeindruckend langer Vertrag dafür, dass er jetzt erstmal der Feuerwehrmann sein wird, aber will sich ihm auf was längeres einlassen. Mit ihm kommt auch Andrej Mijatovic, der ja Aufschießkapitän als Spieler in Berlin war. Und mal sehen, ob die in Berlin dann wieder ihre berühmte WG beziehen werden. Stefan Leitel. Mein erster Eindruck ist, jemand, der weiß, was er tut. Man hört sehr unterschiedliches aus Fürth und Hannover. In Fürth lieben sie ihn, sagen gepflegtes Ballbesitzspiel, sehr intensives Spiel, aber auch wirklich schöner Fußball. Und in Hannover hat man gehört, ja, intensiv und gute Defensive, aber nach vorne gar keinen Plan zu erkennen. Da muss man jetzt mal sehen, was man daraus machen muss. Fadi, hattest du die Ehre, du bist zwar für den Club zuständig, aber auch ein bisschen Kontakt zu Stefan Leitel zu haben, der davor auch noch in Ingolstadt war, also sich da generell in der Region ja sehr etabliert hat.
Ich habe ihn natürlich ein bisschen mitbekommen, nie persönlich kennengelernt, außer bei den Derbys, aber es war ja auch Pandemie-Hochphase. Damals, die Fürther sind ja mehr oder weniger ohne Publikum damals aufgestiegen. Dieses Aufstiegsjahr war großartig der Spielvereinigung. Man hätte sich vielleicht sogar in der ersten Liga halten können, wenn man nicht nach diesem Aufstiegsjahr einfach drei hervorragende Stammspieler, unter anderem David Raum, sofort hätte abgeben müssen, verloren hat. Deshalb ist wirklich Leitel in Fürth immer noch wohl gelitten. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass er auch in Berlin funktioniert, wenn er dort mit der Medienlandschaft sich einigermaßen arrangiert, dass er in Hannover jetzt nicht so gut funktioniert hat, gut wäre. Wer will schon in Hannover funktionieren, deshalb habe ich auch vollstes Verständnis dafür. Ich könnte, könnte, könnte werden.
Zumal er wurde damals bei Hannover auf Platz 3 entlassen. Das haben manche verstanden aufgrund der spielerischen Entwicklung, andere nicht aufgrund der tabellarischen Situation. Und jetzt unter Nachfolge André Bereitenreiter hat Hannover, glaube ich, fünfmal hintereinander unentschieden gespielt. Also das wirklich wahre ist es seitdem ja nun auch nicht. Also ich glaube vielleicht altert die Amtszeit von Stefan Leitl in Hannover besser. Das könnte sein, als sie aktuell altert. Dennis, ich hole dich jetzt bei einem Thema rein, was euch gar nichts angeht, nämlich der Abschiedskampf. Da gibt es ein bisschen, ich sag mal, neues Feuer. Der Jan aus Regensburg hat einen Punkt gegen den HSV geholt. Braunschweig hat Darmstadt geschlagen und damit das zweite Spiel in Folge gewonnen. Und plötzlich stehen Hertha und auch Darmstadt wieder mitten drin im Abschiedskampf. Hat man als FC-Fan überhaupt ein Auge dahin? Oder guckt man gefühlt nur auf die ersten drei Plätze?
Natürlich gucken wir unten hin, alleine weil natürlich der Aufstieg von Regensburg ganz eng mit einem FC-Stürmer verknüpft ist. Adam Jan gehört ja im ersten FC Köln, ist da in Ausglin. Und hat dankenswerterweise jetzt gegen den HSV auch das wichtige Tor erzielt, dass uns die Hamburger ferngehalten hat. Also natürlich, man muss halt in dieser Liga immer drauf achten, was unten passiert. Alleine weil das ja in der Regel Konsequenzen für oben hat, da ja die Hälfte der Liga entweder oben oder unten mitspielt. Insofern ist das schon für uns auch ganz spannend. Und natürlich, mit einem Auge guckt man ja auch immer, was in der Rest der Liga los ist. Und gerade so Regensburg kann glaube ich noch unangenehm werden. Da werden noch viele Mannschaften hinkommen, sich denken, was ist denn das hier für ein Acker? Hat der HSV ja auch kennenlernen müssen, was das für ein Acker ist.
Herrte auch sehr gut, ja.
Ja wir auch, wir haben es trotzdem geschafft, da wie immer 1 zu 0 zu gewinnen. Aber der Rasen hat uns schon ordentlich an den Rand gebracht. Und dann kommt da eben auch eigentlich eine gar nicht so schlechte Qualität auf dem Platz, die nicht ganz sich in der Tabelle widerspiegelt. Aber wenn die da mal ein Tor machen, wird es auch ganz eklig gegen Regensburg selber zu Toren zu kommen. Also ich hab die noch nicht abgeschrieben.
Damian, du hast sie erwähnt, Tim Handwerker geholt, Anzizuhung vom HSV geholt.
Handwerker auch Ex-FC-Spieler, genau.
So, die haben also dementsprechend im Winter auch nochmal gut zugeschlagen. Und das zeigt sich allmählich. Schalke hat sich ja mit dem 2 zu 1 gegen den KSC, und jetzt, ich hab mal geguckt, 14 Punkte aus den letzten acht Spielen. Das ist wirklich in Ordnung. Da unten freigeschwommen. Fadi, du hast viel Erfahrung in der zweiten Liga jetzt durch einen Club. Der ist ja jetzt auch schon eine Weile. Nicht als Spitze gemeint. Reine Realität. Was macht denn diese zweite Liga so unglaublich eklig? Also man hat es ja jetzt bei Hertha gesehen, sobald du nicht mehr um den Aufstieg mitspielst, steckst du mit einem Bein im Abschießkampf. Das ist ja irre.
Ja, ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich liebe diese Liga. Ich hab sie lieben gelernt. Ich finde sie aber auch, dass es eine Platitüde inzwischen interessanter als die erste Liga. Es sind einfach viele Vereine geprägt von Management-Fehlern, die deshalb schlechtere Rollen spielen als sie es könnten. Und dann immer mal wieder welche wie Elversberg oder so, die ein paar kluge Ideen haben. Und dadurch ergibt sich dann diese Gemengelage, das gefühlt auch jetzt noch der 13., der aussteigen kann, ist ein bisschen übertrieben jetzt. Aber ja, einfach eine schöne Liga, in der es wirklich einen Wettbewerbsgedanken mal wieder gibt, den man aus der ersten Liga größtenteils nicht mehr so kennt.
Das ist wohl wahr. Und das dritte Thema, was ich mitgebracht habe oder wir mitgebracht haben, ist eins, wo man jetzt gar nicht groß in die Diskussion kommt, ist nur mal eine Zwischenbeobachtung, die eben so enge zweite Bundesliga erhält, so allmählich so etwas wie die Tabellenregionen, Konturen, wenn man so möchte. Denn mittlerweile gibt es dann vier Punkte Abstand zwischen dem KSC durch diese Niederlage gegen Schalke und Nürnberg, die jetzt 2 zu 0 gewonnen haben. Und jetzt trennt sich hier so allmählich der Auf vom Abschließkampf. Mal sehen wer, also dieses graue Mittelfeld, wie gesagt, gibt es ja gar nicht so richtig, denn selbst Schalke kann sich ja noch nicht sicher wähnen, wenn ich glaube sieben Punkten Abstand auf 16, aber allmählich könnte man erahnen, wohin die Reise bei manchen Vereinen geht. Also ich glaube, dass man da, also ich glaube zum Beispiel nicht, dass der KSC noch mal oben angreift oder siehst du das anders denn ist?
Ich glaube, die müssen nach unten gucken. Ich glaube der KSC hat mit Budo so einen wichtigen Baustein verloren.
Das stimmt.
Der Budo-Civci-Datze, der sich, wenn ich jetzt ein Hot-Tech raushauen müsste, würde ich sagen, dass Christian Eichner-Stuhl demnächst wackeln wird, wenn das so weitergeht, obwohl wir sehr zufrieden mit ihm sind und er sehr, der verwurzelt auch da ist. Aber ich kann mir vorstellen.
Wurde der nicht gerade erst verlängert?
Das ist ja oft so. Du verlängerst den Vertrag und genau dann kommt irgendwie so ein bisschen die Brüche in die Ehe.
Dann ist die Spannung raus.
Das ist ja manchmal so. Ja, aber ich glaube, dass die ja wirklich mit Civci-Datze einen ganz wichtigen Baustein verloren haben. Jetzt sogar gegen Schalke trotz eigentlich einem ganz guten Auftritt verloren haben und irgendwann kriegt sowas ja auch eine Eigendynamik und irgendwann verlieren die Spieler auch so ein bisschen den Glauben. Sieht man ja vielleicht auch ein bisschen gerade bei Darmstadt, wo ja auch so jetzt wieder der Wurm drin ist. Also ich glaube der KSC muss nach unten schielen und nicht nach oben.
Fair. Also Darmstadt, auch da kann man es nochmal erwähnen, da ist der Kohfeldt-Effekt wirklich verpufft, nachdem die ja eine irre Serie hingelegt haben und gefühlte ich auch jedes Tor gemacht haben, was sie hätten machen können, passiert das jetzt eben nicht mehr. Haben nur noch einen Punkt aus den letzten sechs Spielen geholt. Ich hab mir auch da mal die Expected Goals, wir hatten so ein bisschen angeguckt aus den Spielen, da waren auch unglückliche Niederlagen dabei, aber sie haben jetzt auch in keinem Spiel überragt oder es erzwungen. Also ganz komische Saison von Darmstadt. Am Anfang mitten drin, zwischendurch hieß es, vielleicht muss man doch noch mal nach oben schielen und jetzt steckt man wieder hinten drin. Das ist glaube ich nicht so einfach wegzustecken mental.
Ich glaube, das ist bei denen eine klassische Regression zur Mitte. Die haben jetzt halt sechs Spiele überperformed, jetzt haben sie sechs Spiele unterperformed und treffen sich halt genau da, wo Darmstadt hingehört. Aber auch da muss man glaube ich ein bisschen drauf gucken, dass natürlich Isak Liedberg da jetzt lange verletzt war. Der kommt wieder. Ich glaube, das könnte ein Unterschied sein. Wie bei Hertha ja auch. Also wenn da mal wirklich ein Fabian Reese und Diego Demme und so richtig fit sind, ich glaube, das ist nochmal ein anderer Schnack, nochmal eine andere Qualität im Kader.
Definitiv.
Und deswegen glaube ich, dass man bei Darmstadt so ein bisschen gucken muss, ob die unverletzt durch die Saison kommen und ob da nochmal so eine zweite Luft von Flo Co. kommen kann.
Da bin ich sehr gespannt. So, reines tabellarischen Gründen habe ich mich dafür entschieden, dass wir mit dem FC anfangen in dieser Zweitligasendung. Und dementsprechend, Dennis, du bist schon im Redefluss, können wir da weitermachen. Mal die letzten Auftritte zusammengefasst. Eine 0 zu 1 Niederlage gegen den HSV, dann zwei Siege gegen Elbersberg und Braunschweig, dann die deftige 0 zu 3 Pleite gegen Magdeburg jetzt am Wochenende und dazwischen das bittere Ausland-BfB-Pokal gegen Leverkusen. Was macht man aus diesem Rückrundenbeginn? Und vor allen Dingen dann hinten raus, was lief in Magdeburg schief?
Ja, also die gute Nachricht ist ja erstmal, man hat schon mal zwei Punkte mehr als zum selben Zeitpunkt der Hinrunde. Das ist ja schon mal positiv anzumerken, da man die Hinrunde nun mal als Tabellenführer beendet hat. Insofern könnte man jetzt sagen, ist ja nicht viel passiert. Mal auch die Tabellenführung nicht eingebüßt, weil keiner den Patzer genutzt hat. Aber man muss halt sagen, dass diese Niederlage in Magdeburg sich auch lange angekündigt hat. Also im Endeffekt war die Leistung genauso wie bei all den Spielen, die man 1 zu 0 gewonnen hat. Auch da hat man jeweils dem Gegner wirklich riesengroße Chancen ermöglicht, die halt nur vielleicht auch ein bisschen bedingt der Qualität des Gegners nicht ganz zu Toren geführt haben. Aber alleine, wenn man sich das Spiel gegen Schalke, das 1-0 mal anschaut, Kenan Karaman, der eigentlich eine gewisse Qualität hätte, kommt komplett frei am langen Pfosten zum Abschluss und trifft das leere Tor halt einfach nicht. Sondern macht eher so eine Abwehr-Clear-Aktion. Selbe gegen Braunschweig in der 94. Minute kommt ein Stürmer von denen komplett unbedrängt im Kölner Strafraum zum Kopfball und köpft den Maler halt um einen Zentimeter neben den Pfosten. Und Marc Dubock hat eben genau das nicht getan. Die haben halt diese Chancen genutzt, haben dann das 1-0 gemacht und dann lief das Spiel komplett gegen uns auch, weil wir eine Mannschaft sind, die sich sehr schwer damit tut, Rückstände irgendwie zu drehen, weil auch ein bisschen das spielerische Element fehlt. Also das mag jetzt so ein bisschen komisch anmuten, wenn man auf Platz 1 grüßt, aber wir haben keinen richtigen Spielgestalter im Kader. Wir haben einen, die Eltern werden sich erinnern, Marc Uth, aber Marc Uth spielt seit zwei Jahren gefühlt nicht mehr, weil er immer verletzt ist, leider Gottes, und nie mehr richtig auf die Füße gekommen ist in dieser Phase. Aber er wurde auch nie ersetzt vom Kaderplaner. Das heißt, wir haben, wenn man so ein bisschen auf Kreativität gehen will, maximal noch Florian Kainz als Spielgestalter. Und der ist jetzt auch seit zwei Jahren in Form tief gefühlt. Ja, und deswegen fehlt so ein bisschen das Element um eine gut strukturierte und wirklich gut verteidigende Mannschaft wie Darmstadt, wie Quatsch, wie Magdeburg, die so ganz eklig defensiv griffig gegen einen agiert, mit einer Dreier-, Fünferkette und gut verschiebenen Mittelfeldspielern. Da dann durchzukommen, da tun wir uns unheimlich schwer. Und dann bleibt eigentlich fast nur das Element der Ecken. Und wenn diese Ecken eben nicht greifen, ich glaube, wir haben jetzt neun Tore nach Ecken oder so was, wenn wir da eben keine Tore schießen, dann tun wir uns unheimlich schwer, da irgendwie was zu reißen gegen den Gegner, der schon 1-0 führt.
Verstehe. Bevor wir auf die allgemeine sportliche Situation gucken, lass uns gerne kurz über den Transferwinter vom FC reden, denn es war ja ein besonderer, weil man wieder Spieler verpflichten durfte.
Ungewohntes Gefühl, ja.
Ja, mal wieder irgendwie auf transfermarkt.de vorbeischauen, das kennt man gar nicht mehr.
Das erste Gerücht, das kam, hat uns alle so ein bisschen angefixt, weil zum ersten Mal seit eineinhalb Jahren wieder irgendein Name gerüchtet wurde, auch wenn es irgendein vielköniger Spieler war.
Ich wollte gerade sagen.
Es war so, dass Gazi Begovic auch gekommen ist letzten Endes, auch ein gutes Gerücht, aber alleine überhaupt wieder Gerüchte zu lesen, das hat schon was mit einem gemacht.
Das glaub ich sofort. So, wie gesagt, Köln konnte das erstmals wieder Spieler verpflichten und hat gleich auch zugeschlagen mit Innenverteidiger Joel Schmidt, Rechtsverteidiger Jusuf Gazi Begovic und Mittelstürmer Imad Rondic sind drei Spieler für Millionen ablösend gekommen. Wie zufrieden ist man denn in Köln mit dem Transferfenster und den Neuzugängen?
Ja, also erst mal muss man sagen, dass zumindest die Positionen, die verpflichtet worden sind, Sinn ergeben haben. Also gerade diese Rechtsverteidiger Position, die werden glaube ich allen im Kader oder im ganzen Verein so ein Dorn im Auge, wo man gesagt hat, da muss nachgelegt werden und dann auf dem Papier jedenfalls einen Spieler zu holen, der aus der Champions League freiwillig in die zweite Liga geht, um beim rum und glorreichen 1. FC Köln zu spielen. Das ist schon ein kleiner Kuh auf dem Transfermarkt gewesen. Leider ist jetzt nur auf Papier, weil Gazi Birguric sich noch sehr schwer tut, sich an den deutschen Fußball, vielleicht auch an Zweitliga-Fußball zu gewöhnen und vielleicht auch an so eine Rolle als immer Favorit sich zu gewöhnen. Das war vielleicht in Graz auch nicht unbedingt, hat in der Champions League jetzt nicht. Aber er war ja einer der herausragenden Spieler in Österreich, mit einem Kickernotenschnitt von 2,6 oder irgendwas. Also guter Transfer, aber hat noch nicht gezündet, weswegen zuletzt sogar wirklich wieder Jan Thielmann anstatt Gazi Birguric gespielt hat.
Und das war vorher schon immer nur so eine Kompromisse.
Ja, ich mein in einer Fünferkette, wenn er nur die Schiene spielen muss, dann geht das alles sogar. Dafür ist er ein guter Spieler, weil er drauf und runter rennt die Linie, weil er so ein Arbeitstier ist und irgendwie auch 16 Kilometer läuft gegen Leverkusen oder so in 120 Minuten. Und auch wirklich ein Kämpferherz ist. Als Rechtsverteidiger in der Viererkette hat es nie gut funktioniert. Dafür wurde jetzt Gazi Birguric geholt. Ich glaub mit dieser Fünferkette ist er noch nicht ganz so heimisch geworden bis jetzt. Und deswegen hat jetzt in der Tat Jan Thielmann wieder die Nase vorne. Was aber eigentlich auch wieder so ein bisschen gegen die Kaderpolitik spricht, weil Thielmann würde eigentlich vorne gebraucht werden, da man außer Linden Meiner keinen anderen schnellen Spieler im Kader hat, als Stürmer. Und da müsste man eigentlich an Thielmann dann reinschmeißen können, wenn Meiner sich mal ausgepowert hat. Jetzt wird aber wieder rechts gebraucht. Und das ist vielleicht so ein bisschen so das Kernproblem der gesamten Transferpolitik. Es wurde überhaupt nie auf Breite ausgelegt. Weder vor der Transfersperre, als man sich darauf hätte vorbereiten können und müssen. Selbst da wurde der Kader nicht in der Breite aufgebläht irgendwie. Und selbst die beiden Transfers jetzt im Winter noch, also Schmied und Ronditsch, dafür hat man parallel auch jeweils zwei Spiele auf der Position abgegeben. Also für Ronditsch ist ein Stürmer, aber dafür gingen Florian Dietz und der schon erwähnte Sargess Adabian, macht in der Summe einen Stürmer weniger. Dann ist Tim Lemperle noch verletzt, zum Beispiel bei zwei Stürmern weniger. Und hinten hat man auch Bakatou Kanda abgegeben. Und damit ist man auch in der Summe wieder bei Null rausgekommen, sodass der Kader eben vielleicht in der Spitze ein bisschen verbessert wurde. Aber jetzt hat kaum auf die vielen vielen Verletzungen und Ausfälle reagieren kann. Weil der Kader eben kaum Breite hergibt.
Ist ja oft ein Problem auch bei Zweitligisten, dass sie sich eine krasse Breite auch nicht leisten können und vielleicht auch ein bisschen hoffen müssen, dass Eigengewächse in diese Breite wachsen. Hängt das vielleicht auch damit zusammen, dass vielleicht gewisse Talente nicht die Sprünge gemacht haben, die sie hätten tun sollen?
Ich würde sogar eher sagen, dass wir Talente haben, die gerade total überperformen. Also wer hatte vor der Saison darauf gewettet, dass Julian Pauli 16 Spiele macht und sich dann leider gegen Hertha im Pokal am Kopf verletzt und seitdem mit irgendwie neurologischen Problemen ausfällt. Also irgendwie Schwindelgefühle und sowas, also irgendwas gehört, das Geschütterungsmodus.
Das hat Diego Demme in Berlin ja auch erwischt. Das ist ja auch so eine nicht greifbare Sache, weshalb er immer wieder ausfällt aktuell.
Ganz genau. Leider auch dann gegen Hertha noch weiterspielen lassen, trotz der schon vorhandenen Kopfverletzung. Hat ja auch dann zum Elfmeter geführt für Hertha. Und da hätte man vielleicht zum Schutz des Jungen sagen müssen, du kommst jetzt sofort runter. Aber das ist so ein Breakouts-Da-Saison und unser Sturmduo war ja lange Zeit auch. Damian Downs und Tim Lemberle, die beide aus dem eigenen Nachwuchs kommen, weil die jetzt absolut etablierte Zweigliga-Stürmer sind. Und da eben auch so die einzigen Gefahren Hertha eigentlich sind. Also man kann ja nicht vorwerfen, dass die Talente nicht zünden würden. Und selbst jetzt zuletzt gegen Schalke hat man dann die Hotelle in die Mannschaft werfen müssen, wegen der vielen Verletzungen. Der hat es auch gut gemacht, ist jetzt aber leider auch mit dem Infektor wieder ausgefallen. Also man kann den Leuten eigentlich nichts vorwerfen. Und ich glaube langsam ist auch der Rahmen der zweiten Mannschaft dann auch abgeschöpft, sodass da vielleicht auch nicht mehr die ganz großen Sprünge in die Saison jetzt kommen können, weil da glaube ich kein Spieler in der Regionalliga West jetzt so sehr auf sich aufmerksam machen würde, dass man sagt, die muss man auf jeden Fall jetzt unbedingt noch einwerfen bei den Profis.
Apropos Eigengewächse, ein weiterer Transfer im Winter war der Verkauf von Torhüter-Eigengewächse Jonas Obig für rund 7 Millionen, ich glaube plus Boni zum FC Bayern. Wie überraschend kam denn der Abgang und wie bewertest du die Personalien? Denn ja, er ist zwar zur Nummer 2 degradiert worden innerhalb der Saison, Marvin Schwebe ist dann irgendwann wieder zwischen die Pfosten gerutscht, aber ich hatte jetzt nicht das Gefühl, dass deshalb direkt ein Wechsel im Raum steht. Wie bewertest du diese Gesamtsituation im Tor dann?
Ja, also ich glaube, wenn man so ganz genau hinhört und ein bisschen zwischen den Zeilen liest, dann hat dieser Torwartwechsel auch deshalb stattgefunden, weil sich Jonas Obig nicht zum ersten FC Köln kommitten konnte und wollte. Man hat ihm ja die Chance gegeben, hat Schwäbe quasi auf die Bank versetzt, obwohl sich Schwäbe halt nie was hat zur Schulden kommen lassen und auch in der Abstiegsstunde einer der stärksten Spieler war und wirklich auch ein guter Torwart ist oder vielleicht sogar ein sehr guter Torwart für unsere Verhältnisse. Aber man hat trotzdem auf den jungen Mann, auf Obig gesetzt, der aber im Gegenzug dazu nicht bereit war, seinen Vertrag zu verlängern beim FC. Und dann haben sich wohl auch einige, ich sag mal Führungsspieler eher für Schwäbe ausgesprochen. Wohl auch deshalb, weil Obig jemand sein soll, der so sehr Karriere fokussiert ist und sehr auf sein eigenes Ding aus ist. Und so wenig auf, sagen wir mal jetzt, Team-Chemie Wert legt oder auf so Kommunikation mit seinen Mitspielern und so. Was vielleicht der erfahrene Schwäbe ein bisschen besser tut. Und das alles hat eben dazu geführt, dass der Trainer Gerhard Strober nicht nur auf diese 3a-5a-Kette umgestellt hat, sondern auch im Tor einen Wechsel gemacht hat. Und danach folgten halt irgendwie neun Siege aus elf Spielen oder so was. Dann gab es eben keine Argumente mehr, dass man Jonas Orbig zurück ins Tor verlegt. Und dann haben es die Spatzen eigentlich schon von den Dächern gefiffen, dass er uns verlassen wird. Und dann noch für einen jetzt immer Ersatz-Torwart in der 2. Liga, sieben und halb Millionen plus Bonny. Also meine Güte. Da muss man den Reisen noch nicht aufhalten.
Auf keinen Fall. Ich mein, selbst wenn er sich jetzt super entwickelt und doch die Nummer 1 Deutschlands irgendwann wird, zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo man ihn jetzt verkauft hat, hat er die Summe nicht in dem Sinne gerechtfertigt. Er hatte glaube ich ein, zwei sehr vielversprechende Leihstationen.
Rein viert, genau.
Genau. Tja, Torwartwechsel innerhalb der Saison, auch das hat Christian Ferrier bei Hertha probiert. Ich hab ein sehr ähnliches Bild gerade vor Augen, denn da war es ja auch so, dass Thiak Ernst, der hatte zwar schon eine sehr stabile erste Profisaison bei Hertha auf dem Konto, aber in der zweiten Saison jetzt war er sehr wackelig und dann hat man sich im Wintertrainingslager mehr oder weniger dann für Marius Gersberg entschieden. Das hat nur nicht den gewünschten Effekt gebracht. Das ist alles genauso wackelig geblieben wie davor gefühlt. Also es kann auch mal in die Binsen gehen und da kann sich ein Trainer auch mal ein bisschen dran verbrennen.
Das ist aber auch ganz spannend. Man hat ja vor der Saison immer so gesagt, die beiden größten deutschen Torwarttalente, vielleicht neben Noah Atobolo von Freiburg, Thiak Ernst und Jonas Orbig und beide finden sich auf der Bank wieder, zeitgleich schon auch kurios, was so in so einer Saison passieren kann.
Definitiv und bei Hertha ging es ja dann sogar so weit, dass Ernst Berater öffentlich in einem gewissen Springer-Medium gegen den Verein und Christian Pfehl gewettert hat und so weiter. Also es hat so seine Bahn gezogen, aber man konnte es irgendwie wieder einfangen. Spannend wird dann sein, wer dann im Tor steht jetzt gegen Nürnberg dann am Freitag. Das wollte Stefan Leite noch nicht verraten, also es ist 50-50. Blicken wir mal auf die allgemeine Sportesituation beim FC. Man hat zwei seiner letzten elf Spiele nur verloren, dafür im gleichen Zeitraum sechs Mal mit 1 zu 0 gewonnen. Das wirkt sehr stabil. Du hast jetzt aber schon anklinken lassen, Dennis, dass der Eindruck ein bisschen täuschen könnte und da auch eine gehörige Portion Glück dabei ist.
Ja, so ganz kann man diesen Aufschwung eben nicht erklären, wirklich. Also nicht mit irgendwelchen logischen Parametern. In allen Spielen war man relativ ausgeglichen, was die Werte angeht zum Gegner. Auch bei XG und so weiter und so fort kann man nicht immer da erkennen, dass der FC irgendwie die Liga weggrocken würde oder sowas. Aber man hat natürlich ein bisschen es geschafft, diesem sehr attraktiven, aber sehr erfolglosen Fußball der ersten Saison, des ersten Saisons viertels einzutauschen gegen einen sehr unattraktiven, aber sehr stabilen und sehr erfolgsfokussierten Fußball. Das erinnert jetzt manche Beobachter wieder an die guten alten Peter Stöger Zeiten. Also die Null muss stehen quasi hinten. Das schafft man schon ganz gut, auch wenn ich ja schon dargelegt habe, da auch ein bisschen Glück seitens der Abschlussschwäche des Gegners mit dabei war. Man sieht aber auch, wenn eine Mannschaft mal wirklich gegen uns performt, wie Magdeburg, wir haben auch Darmstadt bei den 5 zu 1, dann haben wir auch wenig entgegenzusetzen, weil wir uns da doch sehr, sehr schwer tun. Weil jeder bei uns in der Mannschaft einen Patzer pro Spiel auch drin hat defensiv. Und dann sieht es halt eben schon manchmal ziemlich dunkel aus. Ja und dazu kommt eben auch noch, dass wir, hab ich gerade schon mal erwähnt, wenn man die Stärke bei Eckbällen rausrechnet, uns unheimlich schwert darum, aus dem Spiel heraus hohe XG-Werte zu erzielen.
Was interessant ist, da grätsch ich mal ganz kurz rein, denn ich hab mir auch die Zahlen ein bisschen angeguckt und das Interessante ist, dass man den zweithöchsten XG-Wert der Liga hat, aber man hat auch mit Abstand die meisten Abschlüsse. Also kann es einfach sein, dass Köln sehr oft schießt und dadurch hohe XG-Werte in Summe erzielt, aber keine hochkarätigen Chancen?
Ja, man müsste die Statistik auch ein bisschen bereinigen, glaube ich. Und man müsste trennen vor dem Pokalspiel gegen Kiel und nach dem Pokalspiel gegen Kiel. Weil das war der Moment, wo wir auf die Dreierkette umgestellt haben. Seitdem laufen die Ergebnisse, aber ich würde wetten, dass seitdem der XG-Wert um 1,0 im Schnitt gesunken ist oder so. Weil davor war es ja dieser ganz wilde Chaos-Fußball, der so ein bisschen an so Tim-Walter-Ball erinnert hat, irgendwie vorne wirklich eine Hochzahl an Chancen. Bestes Beispiel, das Spiel gegen den KSC, hat man 3-1 geführt und dann plötzlich noch 4-4 gespielt hinten raus. Ganz, ganz wildes Spiel.
Ich erinnere mich auch an den ersten Spieltag gegen den HSV, das durfte man ja auch niemals verlieren.
Und das Hinspiel gegen Magdeburg, da waren wir wirklich drückend überlegen und haben trotzdem 1-2 verloren. Aber das ist alles seit diesem Stabilitätsfokus jetzt nach dem Kiel-Spiel nicht mehr der Fall. Ich würde auch wetten, wenn man das irgendwie aufteilen könnte, würde man sehen, dass der XG sich da irgendwo bei 1,1 oder so einläuft oder sowas. Und da sind schon die Ecken mit drin. Also da ist schon, da hat schon ein ganz klarer Fokus auf dem Platz stattgefunden, eher Richtung Defensive als nach vorne noch Hurra-Fußball anzubieten. Was aber bemerkenswert ist, dass man es auch nie wieder geschafft hat, in diesen Modus von Anfang der Saison zu schalten. Dass man zumindest bei Rückstand sagt, okay komm, jetzt ist egal, jetzt Hose runter und wir laufen jetzt alle nach vorne. Das schafft man irgendwie auch nicht mehr. Also man hat jetzt kaum noch Spieler vorm Ball, während vorher teilweise bis zu sieben Spieler vorm Ball und in und um der Box herum standen. Deswegen als wir auch viele Abschlüsse dann vom Blaster fallen mussten. Während jetzt halt wirklich so der Plan ist, schickt den Linden meiner lang, der kann 36 kmh schnell laufen. Das reicht in der zweiten Liga meistens, um den Abwehrspielern wegzulaufen. Damian Downs auch ein schneller Spieler mit einer guten Abschlussstärke. Anscheinend ist das wirklich der Matchplan, gerade zu sagen, ja ihr beiden macht das schon. Der Rest bleibt hinten und guckt sich das interessiert an, was ihr da so macht. Aber greift auch nicht allzu sehr jetzt das Geschehen ein, damit genug Spieler hinterm Ball sind.
Fadi, ich wollte sagen, du wolltest dich eh einschalten.
Ja genau, ich wollte einfach eine grundsätzliche Einschätzung von euch beiden. Es ist nicht schade, dass man diesen Chaos-Fußball dann irgendwann abschafft und nur noch auf dir. Ist ja nicht in Köln als einzigen Standort so. Aber wie es da euer denkt, seid ihr eher, ich bin eher fürs Chaos und dann lieber sieben Dinger verballern und am Ende 1-0 gegen Paderborn verlieren oder sowas, als dieses zynische Ergebnis-Fußball und dann am Ende in die erste Liga aufsteigen. Also wäre ich Trainer, ich würde mich immer für den Spaß entscheiden.
Es ist so schwierig, denn am Ende zählt halt das eine die eine Geschichte und das andere andere. Wenn ich dann die erfolgreichen Jahre in der ersten Amtszeit von Pall Darday zurückdenke, dann war das größtenteils eklige Ergebnis-Fußball und vorne hatte man halt weder Bischofetsch noch Salomon Calou und das hat dann irgendwie immer gereicht. Und damit hat man nochmal europäisch gespielt. Wir waren in Bilbao und so weiter. Das interessiert dann zehn Jahre später, niemand mehr wieder zustande gekommen ist. Also auch das sehen wir auch bei Nico Kovac und Eintracht Frankfurt. Klar, Frankfurt war auch danach erfolgreich, aber wieder jetzt genau die Mannschaft damals gerettet und zum DFB-Pokal gesiegt gecoacht hat, ziemlich egal. Also natürlich, wir alle, wir machen den Podcast hier, wir bloggen, wir sind Journalisten, weil wir diesen Sport lieben und das Spiel lieben. Und deswegen ist natürlich immer toll, wenn es heiß hergeht. Und deswegen hat man sich ja in Berlin auch ein Stück weit trotz aller Skepsis darüber gefreut, dass sich die Verantwortlichen für einen mutigen Fußball entschieden haben mit Christian Fjell. Man hat aber eben auch gesehen, was passiert, wenn dieser mutige Fußball zu nichts führt und hat sich ja jetzt auch wieder zu mehr, ich sag mal, Hausmannskost entschieden mit Stefan Leitel, was halt ein bisschen kalkulierbarer ist. Also am Ende greift dieser Reflex irgendwann doch, wenn die Ergebnisse ausbleiben. In Köln hat man sich zumindest die Trainerattraktion gespart. Das ist ja auch mal ganz nett.
Ja eben, das darf man auch nicht vergessen. Da hängert der Job von Gerhard Strohbein dran. Der war vor diesem Pokalspiel, wo er umgestellt hat, eigentlich schon de facto entlassen. Alle haben gesagt, wenn das gegen Kiel schief geht, wenn man im DFB-Pokal gegen einen, zwei Erstligisten, aber jetzt eher unter dem Tabellenstand der ersten Liga, wenn man da ausschaltet im Heimspiel, dann war's das für Strohbein. Und dann hat er halt gesagt, ja okay, dann jetzt halt Pragmatismus. Und ja unterm Strich, ich glaube, es ist sehr wichtig für den Verein aufzusteigen. Und da sind mir die Mittel eigentlich fast egal. Klar, wenn ich mir was wünschen dürfte, dann spielen wir wie Pep Guardiola bei den Bayern, gewinnt jedes Spiel 7 zu 0. Und Stefan Thiges macht drei Fahrrückzieherspiele, Tore pro Spiel. Wird eher nicht passieren. Dann nehme ich halt im Zweifel lieber ein 1-1, ein 1-0 als ein 4-4. Da muss ich dann schon sagen, da bin ich Pragmatiker und möchte irgendwie raus aus der zweiten Liga, um nicht der HSV oder sorry Nürnberg zu werden. Also, ja.
Ja, das seid ihr wahrscheinlich einfach nur klüger als ich.
Wenn der eigene Job dran hängt, glaube ich, denkt man da eh anders drüber. Wahrscheinlich der eigene Erfolg.
Ich glaube auch, das hat man ja auch in Berlin gesehen. Benni Weber und Co. haben wirklich überlange an Christian Pfeil festgehalten. Eigentlich hätte man das schon nach der Hinrunde, wenn man ganz pragmatisch ist und auch ein bisschen zynisch, Fadi. Das stimmt schon, auch da schon die Nummer beenden müssen. Aber man hat halt an diesen Fußball geglaubt. Und naja, ist ein bisschen später auf die Schnauze gefallen. Denn du hast gesagt, man will einfach aus dieser Liga raus. Und das sieht ja aktuell nicht so schlecht aus. Man steht ja an der Tabellenspitze. Mehr kann der FC-Stand jetzt nicht erreichen. Und gleichzeitig hat man in dieser Liga, in der gefühlt jeder ständig über sich selber stolpert, sich tabellarisch nicht absetzen können. Ich hab mich gefragt, wie ist denn jetzt die Stimmung beim FC, wenn man auf die gesamte Saison blickt? Ist da Euphorie, Zufriedenheit, leichtes Grumeln, Nervosität? Was ist da die Gefühlslage?
Ja, für den Tabellenführer überraschend negativ, würde ich fast mal sagen. Ich mein, es ist Köln. Natürlich sind wir immer ein bisschen jeck und natürlich sind wir immer ein bisschen realitätsverklärend, würde ich mal sagen. Und jetzt ist ja gerade wieder Karnevalssaison. Das heißt, jetzt wird es eher noch ein bisschen, noch ein bisschen realitätsverklärender wahrscheinlich werden. Aber zufrieden ist man nicht. Man ist weder zufrieden mit der Arbeit, die Christian Keller liefert, weil halt auch dieser Abstieg noch in den Knochen hängt, der wirklich wirklich hausgemacht war, trotz Transfersperre, die ja auch wiederum hausgemacht war. Also das ist ja auch nicht irgendwie als Naturgesetz von oben heraus auf uns gekommen. Es war ja auch eigenes Verschulden. Und das alles hat eben dazu geführt, dass die Stimmung jetzt nicht positiv ist und dass leider auch so ein bisschen die großen Signale fehlen, die einen so ein bisschen optimistisch in die Zukunft blicken lassen. Also bestes Beispiel ist ja so ein Tim Lemberle, der jetzt halt seine Breakout-Saison hatte und wirklich ein ganz, ganz hervorragender Stürmer ist in der zweiten Liga, uns aber jetzt im Sommer nicht nur ablösefrei verlassen wird, sondern als Stich wirklich ins jedes Kölner Herz auch noch ablösefrei zu TSG Hoffenheim.
Ist das offiziell?
Ja, die haben es verkündet, aber ich hab gehört der Vertrag wird nur für die erste Liga, also vielleicht wird er noch mal zu haben sein, wer weiß. Oder eine Relegation Köln gegen Hoffenheim oder was, wer weiß was für, was für Geschichten das Spiel um Lemberle zukommt. Ja genau. Aber natürlich, also im Selbstverständnis der Kölner verlässt man so eine Narrenburg mit geiler Stimmung, mit tollen Fans, cooler Choreo für so einen, ja, mit wenig interessanten Verein, irgendwo in der Provinz. Das kann auch nicht jeder Kölner so ganz verknüsten. Und dass es dann halt noch ablösefrei geschieht, ist schon ein Stich. Obeck ist für viel Geld gegangen, aber er ist halt auch gegangen. Also das nächste Talent aus unserer eigenen Jugend ist weg. Ein anderer Spieler und da kann man jetzt vielleicht Fadi auch ins Boot holen. Jens Kastrop, den haben wir auch weggeschickt und haben den für wirklich sehr wenig Geld nach Nürnberg transferiert. Hätten eine Rückkaufoption gehabt, haben sie nicht gezogen. Jetzt geht er für 400 Millionen nach ausgerechnet Gladbach auch noch.
Natürlich.
Da verdienen wir ein bisschen was dran, eine kleine Weiterverkaufsgebühr, aber der hätte uns auch sehr gut zu Gesicht gestanden in einer Mannschaft, die gerade im Mittelfeld auch sehr dünn besetzt ist. Auch wieder ein Talent, das einem verloren geht und die anderen Talente, die noch da sind, Damian Downs und Co. sind alle noch nicht dabei, ihren Vertrag zu verlängern, wollen vielleicht gucken, in welcher Liga man spielt. Man weiß noch nicht genau, ob es Gespräche gab oder nicht. Von Seiten des FCs wird nicht kommuniziert und das hat so ein bisschen Schade, weil wir das Gefühl haben, so eigentlich wäre ein gutes, cooles Fundament da gewesen. Auch wirklich in der Transfer-Sperre mit jungen Leuten. Man hat immer gesagt, man will das Bild Bau des Rheinlandes sein, so mit jungen Spielern aus der Region, wenn wir was Cooles aufbauen.
Da sind wir wieder bei den Utopien, die man sich als Fan aufbaut.
Ja, aber andererseits, man kann ja keine Spieler holen. Also man hat ja schon ein anderes Wahl.
Wenn, dann, dann.
Genau, wenn nicht jetzt, wann, dann, so nach dem Motto. Und davon ist ja nicht mehr viel übrig, weil schon ganz viele weg sind oder weggehen werden. Und manchmal eben auch mit Ausnahme von Urbeck unterwehrt. Und das tut dann schon auch weh.
Wie macht sich denn Jens Kastrup, also hat jeder geglaubt, dass Jens Kastrup dann spätestens im Sommer weg ist, Fadi, weil er sich so gut macht? Ich hab schon das Gefühl, dass er einer der auffälligeren Spieler dieser Liga ist.
Ja, erstmal Begeisterung für Bilbao des Rheinlands. Das werde ich versuchen, irgendwie hier auch in Nürnberg einzuführen.
Wir arbeiten nicht mehr mit diesen verrückten Titeln hier beim Rasenfunk, eher so Buzzword gesteuert, das wäre aber ein fantastischer Titel gewesen.
Das wäre tatsächlich ein sehr guter Titel. Ja, das muss man tatsächlich sagen, dass die Verantwortlichen hier, das heißt damals noch Dieter Hecking und Olaf Rebbe in Jens Kastrup, sehr viel gesehen haben und es auch immer wieder betont haben und sich in Nürnberg sehr viele Menschen sehr gewundert haben, warum der FC den gehen lässt. War in seinen ersten Spielzeiten hier noch ein bisschen zu stürmisch und hatte so mehr gelbe Karten als Assists und Tore gesammelt in den Saisons und in dieser Saison einfach hat wieder einigermaßen viele gelbe Karten, aber man hat nicht mehr Angst, dass er minutlich vom Platz fliegen kann. Und ist wirklich ein sehr viel reiferer Spieler hier in Nürnberg geworden. Also vielen Dank für das viele Geld danach können.
Aber dann sind wir eigentlich schon bei einer Personalie, Dennis, die dazu sehr gut passt, nämlich Christian Keller. Der hat jetzt dementiert, dass es im Winter sogar ein Rücktrittsangebot an den Verein gab, aber allein dass Menschen daran geglaubt haben, zeigt ja vielleicht, dass er in Köln eben nicht unumstritten ist. Wie bewährt es denn die Arbeit des Geschäftsjurorsport in Köln?
Ich muss ehrlicherweise sagen, ich bin kein großer Fan von ihm. Also ich finde gerade Nürnberg ist auch so ein Beispiel, wie viel Geld man für Eigengewächse oder für junge Spieler bekommen kann. Und das sehe ich bei uns noch nicht. Man muss einfach nur mal gucken, mit welchem Kader hat Christian Keller angefangen beim ersten FC Köln und welche Spieler spielen jetzt bei uns. Und dann sieht man schon, da ist einfach eine Schröpfung des Kaders, die da stattgefunden hat. Also alleine wenn ich jetzt mal nur ein paar Abgänge aufzähle, Salli Öcal, Elias Giri, Karriereende technisch gesehen Jonas Hektor, aber auch ein Davy Selke und das sind alle Spieler, die er verloren hat, die aber auch nie in irgendeiner Art und Weise ersetzt worden sind. Also wenn man seine Transfers anguckt, stehen halt die ganzen Adamians, Steffen Tigges und so weiter, die ich jetzt, das sind alles total feine Kerle, ich will die auch nicht irgendwie abwerten, die haben aber nicht die Qualität von den Spielern, die man abgegeben hat. Und das führt eben natürlich auch dazu, dass man absteigt, ganz einfach. Und auch sang- und klanglos absteigt. Und am letzten Spieltag noch 4 zu 1 gegen den Aufsteiger aus Heidenheim verliert, die jetzt ja nominell auch nicht den besseren Kader haben, noch nicht einen höheren Kaderwert gehabt hätten oder sowas. Aber man war ja in dem Spiel komplett chancenlos und war in der ganzen Saison eben auch chancenlos. Auch deshalb, weil Christian Keller ist so jemand, der braucht für jeden Transfer gefühlt sehr, sehr lange, weil er ganz, ganz viele, weil sich ganz viel da durch den Kopf gehen lässt, so ein bisschen dieses Moneyball-System wählt, also datengestützte Transfers und Parameter aufstellt. Und dann muss es auch alles Assessment Center durchlaufen und sowas. Das sind alles sehr langwierige Prozesse bei ihm, die aber meiner Meinung nach nicht immer den gewünschten Effekt bringen. Also ich glaube, er wär selber gern so eine Art Diamantenauge, aller Müsli-in-tat, Ben Manga und Co. Aber es fehlt so ein Transfer bei ihm, wo man sagt so wow, der ist cool. Da würde ich noch am ehesten vielleicht so einen Erik Martel nennen, den er halt aus Regensburg mitgebracht hat, wo er selber halt früher Sportchef war. Also der hat bei ihm vor der Haustür gekickt. Das war jetzt auch nicht, dass er den mega gut gescouchtet hätte, der war einfach schon da und er kannte ihn halt und hat ihn mitgebracht. Und toller Spieler, Erik Martel, Kapitän der Deutschen U21. Jeder Bundesligist sucht gerade eine deutschsprachige Holding Six. Und wir haben eine, also super. Aber wenn man sich die anderen Transfers mal anschaut, ja, das hat schon einen Grund warum man abgestiegen ist. Und ich hab's gerade schon mal angedeutet, man hat sich weder transfertechnisch auf die Transfersperre vorbereitet und die wurde ja für eine Saison erstmal ausgesetzt für ein Transferfenster. Das heißt, man hätte noch mal reagieren können, hat aber halt nur Lea Atbakerada geholt, der jetzt aber auch für die erste Liga, ja da hat's nicht gereicht. In der zweiten, alles gut, der war ja auch bei St. Pauli, so ein bisschen der Breakout-Spieler und der Kapitän von St. Pauli und so, hat jetzt glaube ich auch schon sechs oder sieben Vorlagen oder irgendwas. Dafür ist es halt gut, aber für die erste wird's dünn. Und wenn man dann so untermstrichene Bilanz ziehen will, da muss man sagen, seine größten Erfolge bis jetzt waren, dass halt viele Spieler geblieben sind, trotz Abstieg. Also Timo Hübers kann man dann nennen, Linden Meiner, Dejan Juvicic, Luca Waldschmidt sind alle geblieben. Nur alleine, wenn ich jetzt mal diesen Rondage-Transfer mir angucke, der hat je nach Medienberichten irgendwas zwischen 1,5 und 2,5 Millionen gekostet. Und dann denke ich mir, ist es okay, ist guter Spieler, hat in Polen gerade eine tolle Hinrunde gespielt. Aber du warst nicht bereit, dein Angebot an Davy Selke ein bisschen zu erhöhen, der halt schon im Verein gewesen ist. Und hättest du diese 1,5 Millionen, die da korrekt portiert werden, einfach in den schon etablierten Davy Selke gesteckt oder da rein investiert, der wäre gerne geblieben, hat man so gehört. Und jetzt hast du halt unterm Strich, in der Hinrunde hat sie einen Stürmer zu wenig, der hat ein bisschen etabliert und erfahren ist und die Qualität von Selke mitbringt. A. Und B hast du noch deinen größten Konkurrenten, den HSV, quasi ablösefrei verstärkt mit Davy Selke. Und das finde ich dann kein gutes Management, ehrlich gesagt.
Apropos Management, ich muss Zeitmanagement betreiben und dich in einer Frage auf möglichst kurze Sätze festnageln. Denn Butter bei die Fische. Jetzt haben wir viel gehört. Zum einen glaubst du an den Aufstieg und zweitens, das perfekte, ich kann moderieren. Sehr gut. Kann sich der Verein es überhaupt leisten, länger in der zweiten Liga zu verbleiben? Was wäre denn die Perspektive beim Nichtaufstieg? Wir haben über gewisse Vertragssituationen und so weiter ja schon geredet.
Also ja und nein. Ja, wir steigen auf. Nein, wir können es nicht leisten, in der zweiten Liga zu bleiben. Es laufen ganz viele Schlüsselverträge jetzt aus zum Sommer. Jubicic, Lämpere, Meiner habe ich schon genannt. Und das sind die wichtigsten und die bleiben nur bei Aufstieg. Das steht jetzt schon fest. Dazu kommt, dass noch mehr Verträge 2026 auslaufen.
Ich hab's gesehen. Hübers, Thielmann, Martel, Finke.
Die ganze erste Elfgräfin. Und jetzt ohne zu kleinteilig zu werden in der U21 sieht es genauso aus. Und das heißt, diese Spieler bleiben ja nicht drei Jahre in der zweiten Liga. So, das heißt, die wollen alle aufsteigen. Die sehen sich alle als Bundesliga-Spieler und eine Chance und Verlängerung hat man nur, wenn man bleibt. Die bleiben nur, wenn wir aufsteigen. Und deshalb ist der Aufstieg elementar.
Siehst du, auch das spiegelt sich in härter Situation genauso wieder. Hier muss man sich damit beschäftigen, dass es eh nicht hochgeht. Und dann endet im Sommer auch so ein Zyklus mit Ivo Maser, Fabian Reese und Co. Da kann man vielleicht mal ein bisschen drauf gucken und gucken, was passiert wäre. Aber wir glauben jetzt ja alle mal gemeinsam an den FC-Aufstieg und dann ist es gut. Und dann bedanke ich mich schon mal an der Stelle. Denn es bleibt aber gerne aufmerksam und grätsch bei Fadi rein, wenn der irgendwas erzählt, was du spannend findest. Denn wir kommen jetzt zum ersten FC Nürnberg, Fadi. Und ich starte mal bewusst provokant in das Segment. Viele hätten nicht geglaubt, dass wir nach dem 22. Spieltag noch über Nürnberg mit dem mit Miroslav Klose als Trainer sprechen. Doch durch eine positive Entwicklung und nach einem heuprigen Start und nun immerhin 34 Punkten auf dem Konto sitzt er fest im Sattel. Wie ist das Klose gelungen? Hat er sich auch weiterentwickelt? Warum passt es so gut zwischen ihm und Nürnberg?
Viele hätten nicht erwartet, vor allem ich hätte nicht erwartet. Ich war ja glaube ich das letzte Mal im September zu Gast und hab da nach der Heimniederlage gegen die gegen die Härter sehr ausführlich erklärt, warum Miroslav Klose im Leben kein Trainer werden wird. Miroslav Klose ist immer noch da, also da sollte man alles, genau diese Aussage sollte man im Hinterkopf haben bei all dem, was ich jetzt in den nächsten fünf Minuten erzähle. Es hat praktisch alle in Nürnberg überrascht, dass Miroslav Klose nach einem wirklich heulprig bis schlimmen Saisonstart die Kurve noch bekommen hat. Es gab da ja dann noch die Niederlage in Hannover nach dem Spiel daheim gegen die Hertha. Da vielleicht hat die Wende begonnen, auch da wie in Köln eine Umstellung auf eine Dreierkette, eine Defensive, sodass ein bisschen Stabilität, man hat dieses Spiel trotzdem verloren, aber es ging so ein bisschen besser, man hat es einigermaßen lange offen halten können. Dann kam noch ein sehr holpriges Spiel gegen Preußen Münster daheim, 3 zu 2, Sieg und danach das Derby in Fürth, der 1. FC Nürnberg gewinnt 4 zu 0 und sieht aus, als hätte er den schönen und erfolgreichen Fußball gefunden.
Ich würde sagen, ein absolutes Freak-Spiel, oder?
Ein absolutes Freak-Spiel, allerdings auch in der Höhe, verdienter Erfolg für den 1. FC Nürnberg. In Fürth sind sie es nicht gewohnt, gegen den 1. FC N zu verlieren, haben deshalb danach praktisch jeden rausgeschmissen, wir so irgendwie unter Vertragsstand von den Verantwortlichen. Ja, und seitdem läuft zwar am 1. FC Nürnberg, man muss sagen, Jüroslav Klose auch am Anfang, wie man ihn vielleicht auch noch so aus seiner Spielerkarriere kennt, jetzt in der öffentlichen Darstellung nicht der absolut überzeugendste, kein großer Redner, hat auch da sehr dazu gewonnen, also es ist ein kleines Rätsel, aber der 1. FC Nürnberg spielt tatsächlich gut Fußball, hat mit der Systemumstellung zu tun und dann einfach mit 1, 2, 3 guten Transfers auch wieder im vergangenen Sommer und auch mit Jens Kastrup, der sich wirklich enorm gesteigert hat.
Du sprichst den Spieler schon an, Klose muss ja einen fast schon absurd jungen Kader coachen, da laufen ja wirklich gefühlt nur noch 19-Jährige und Junge rum. Es sind ja aber auch mit Robin Knoche und Co. ein paar wichtige Konstanten auf dem Feld. Wer sind denn so die Eckpfeiler in der Mannschaft, an die den vielen unerfahrenen Talenten Halt geben können?
Ist tatsächlich Knoche, der auch große Probleme hatte zu Saisonbeginn. Hauptsächlich glaube ich wegen ihm ist dann auch diese Umstellung auf die 3er Kette erfolgt, weil man einfach gesehen hat, dass das Knoche in der 4er Kette nicht so wirklich funktioniert. Schnelligkeitsdefizite und so weiter. Dann ist es Stefanos Zimas, über den wir sicherlich auch noch ein bisschen ausführlicher sprechen werden und Caspar Yanda aus der 3. Liga vom Absteiger aus Duisburg gekommen. Und seitdem der im defensiven Mittelfeld auf der 6 spielen darf, auch spielt der 1. FC Nürnberg guten Fußball.
Ja, bei Caspar Yanda kann ich auch nur Lobesinnend anstimmen. Ich hab so erste Bilder irgendwann mal aus Duisburg gesehen und dachte so, ja der könnte was werden und dann schnappt den sich Nürnberg ablösefrei und ich bin mit sie. Selbst über den kann man im Sommer vielleicht schon über den Bundesligatransfer reden. Der ist irre gut. Der ist irre gut.
Genau. Also es war jetzt nicht die große Idee ihn zu verpflichten, weil wie du sagst, der hat in der in der 3. Liga schon auf sich aufmerksam gemacht, dass sie ihn nach Nürnberg bekommen haben. Dieter Hecking und Olaf Rebbe waren guter Move und er wird tatsächlich auch auch immer teurer und teurer, auch wenn der Chefverkäufer jetzt nicht mehr nicht mehr im Verein ist.
Man hat nur eine Niederlage aus den letzten sechs Spielen kassiert, zuletzt drei Siege in Folge feiern können und ist damit die zweitbeste Rückrundenmannschaft. Hat das Team seit Dezember noch mal einen krassen Entwicklungsschritt hingelegt oder ist da auch Ergebnisglück dabei, wie es in Köln ja dann unter der Haube doch auch zu sehen ist?
Ergebnisglück, würde ich gar nicht sagen. Es sind relativ viele Spiele spät entschieden worden. Also gegen den KSC hat man spät gewonnen, gegen in Magdeburg spät gewonnen, gegen Darmstadt ein spätes Tor zum Sieg. Jetzt am Wochenende wieder gegen Ulm in der 86. Minute, glaube ich, Jan da mit dem 1 zu 0. Sie wirken, auch wenn es nach dem 4 zu 3 in Darmstadt vielleicht ein bisschen komisch klingt, aber defensiv sehr viel stabiler jetzt in der Rückrunde. Und auch geduldiger, also sie scheinen sich jetzt auf ihre Defensive einigermaßen zu verlassen und wissen tatsächlich im Moment, dass sie vorne einfach so gefährlich sind, dass da immer was passieren kann, auch wenn es ungewöhnliche Tore sind. Also es hat einmal ein eingewechselter defensiver Mittelfeldspieler Florian Flick das entscheidende Tor geschossen, dann mal einen Innenverteidiger eingewechselt das entscheidende Tor geschossen, mit Tim Drexler und sowas. Aber sie wirken im Moment tatsächlich gefestigter als noch als noch in der Vorrinde und vor allem gefestigter als man das von so einer jungen Mannschaft grundsätzlich erwarten darf.
Nun ist allerdings ja nicht alles rosig beim Club. Natürlich nicht, man muss sich auch immer etwas treu bleiben. Olaf Rebbe ist seit wenigen Tagen sehr überraschend nicht mehr Sportdirektor des Vereins. Wie kam es dazu?
Muss man auch wieder ein bisschen ein bisschen weiter ausholen. Vielleicht Olaf Rebbe wäre im April jetzt seit vier Jahren in Nürnberg gewesen. Er ist damals von Dieter Hecking verpflichtet worden, als Dieter Hecking gemerkt hat, dass es vielleicht doch ein bisschen was anderes ist, Sportvorstand zu sein als Trainer. Olaf Rebbe hat ja vorher in Wolfsburg gearbeitet, in England, in Griechenland, bei Pahock und so was. Und alles somit so überschaubarm erfolgt. Das heißt, er wurde hier von Anfang an jetzt nicht so als der große Heilsbringer gesehen. Eher haben sich die Menschen gedacht, warum holt sich Hecking einen, der mehr oder weniger gleichberechtigt ist, jetzt noch mal an die Seite, kostet Geld und so was. Geld hat der 1. FC Nürnberg nicht. Dann hat sich aber herausgestellt, dass Olaf Rebbe ganz offenbar ein sehr guter Verhandler ist. So diesen Ruf hat er auch selbst ein bisschen befeuert. Der 1. FC Nürnberg hat es in der Zeit immer wieder geschafft, auch Spieler noch einigermaßen einträglich zu verkaufen, die eigentlich in Nürnberg gar keine große Rolle mehr spielen. Also Mats Meladeli wurde letztes Jahr, als er wirklich kaum noch Einsatzzeiten hat, dann mal für 2,5 Millionen, glaube ich, noch nach Norwegen transferiert. Quattrodur wurde nach einer Saison für sehr viel Geld nach Bulgarien abgegeben. Kilian Fischer an den VfL Wolfsburg nach einer guten Zweitligasaison in Nürnberg und so was. Sie haben tatsächlich dem 1. FC Nürnberg in dieser Kombination relativ viel Geld eingebracht. Geld, das der 1. FC Nürnberg sehr dringend braucht. Sie haben es aber beide gemeinsam nicht geschafft, den 1. FC Nürnberg sportlich zu entwickeln. Also es blieb immer die zweite Liga, weil es ihnen nicht gelungen ist, auch eine stimmige Mannschaft zusammenzustellen. Also sie haben immer mal wieder herausragende Einzelspieler verpflichtet oder dann auch Einzelspieler für gutes Geld verkauft, was für Verhandlungsgeschick spricht. Aber es war nie eine Mannschaft, wo man sich dachte, okay, mit der muss man aufsteigen stattdessen auch immer mal wieder Abstiegsgefahr und so was.
Also es hat die Vision gefehlt.
Es hat ein bisschen die Vision gefehlt, war auch immer die Frage, wie modern ist das Scouting beim ersten FC in Nürnberg. Das sah bei Olaf Rebbe und bei Dieter Hecking immer eher so nach Notizbuch und beraterfixierten Scouting aus und Transfers aus. Und als dann im Sommer letztes Jahr das Hecking gehen musste und Joti HC Alexio vom DFB nach Nürnberg kam, um neuer Sportverstand zu werden, hat der ja auch relativ schnell deutlich gemacht, dass er mit der Mannschaft, die da in der letzten Saison war, überhaupt nicht einverstanden war. Und es mussten sehr viele Spieler gehen, es kamen sehr viele neue Spieler. Und HC Alexio sagt auch immer wieder, Nürnberg muss endlich auch ein datenbasiertes Scouting aufgebaut werden und so was. Also es war so ein Buch ist das ja ja gibt's gab's einige möchte ich jetzt keine Namen nennen, wer so ein bisschen die die Meinung hatte. Aber man hätte sich da schon denken können, dass er sich von Olaf Rebell trennt. Hat er nicht gemacht. Es schien so ein bisschen, als würden die beiden gut zusammenarbeiten. Ich meine, man trennt sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht von einem der John Usun und Samuel Brown für relativ gutes Geld nach zur Eintracht Frankfurt verkauft und so was.
Knapp 15 Millionen.
Ja, darüber wird in Nürnberg ein bisschen gestritten. Es kamen dann auch wieder Zahlen während der Mitgliederversammlung heraus, dass das Ganze nicht ganz so einträglich war, weil Beraterkosten, Steuern und sonstiges dann vielleicht auch noch auch noch eine Rolle spielen. Aber ja, es war jetzt auch nicht schwer, die beiden zu verkaufen, weil wirklich Ausnahmetalente, wie man jetzt auch in Frankfurt sieht, die sind dann auch mehr oder weniger in Schoß gefallen. Das war jetzt kein Scouting von den beiden, sondern die kommen aus dem Nachwuchs und haben halt einfach überragend performt letztes Jahr in der zweiten Liga. Und dann kam jetzt diese Winter-Transfer-Periode, indem er, wie gesagt, Jens Kastrup nach Mönchengladbach verkauft hat, sehr kurzfristig für den Jelcz, ebenfalls aus der eigenen Jugend, junger Innenverteidiger, U17-Europameister, Weltmeister, der sich so wirklich gut etabliert hatte, aber man merkte, dass er noch ein sehr junger Spieler ist, kurzfristig für 10 Millionen knapp zum VfB Stuttgart und dann das Meisterwerk von Olaf Rebe Stefanos Zimas für 25 Millionen nach England zu verkaufen. Einen Spieler, dem er sich von Pauk geliehen hatte, für ein Jahr mit einer Kaufoption über 18 Millionen von der Olaf Rebe sagt, erster FC Nürnberg würde sie wohl ziehen, am Ende der Saison schon als Zimas gekauft wurde und Nürnberg lachte über Olaf Rebe und dann war es tatsächlich so, dass man diesen Deal machen konnte, bleibt auch noch ein bisschen Geld für den ersten FC Nürnberg übrig.
Ein Husarrenstück, würde man in alter Sprache sagen.
Tatsächlich, da kann man ja wirklich nichts dagegen sagen, dass das für einen Zweitligisten in dieser Saison wirklich, in dieser Wintertransferphase wirklich eine herausragende Transferbilanz ist.
Man hat ja für eine Million Euro auch noch Kanji Okunuki verkauft, Joseph Hangbo, also auch diese kleinen Transfersoren, die auch nicht funktioniert haben und wieder für Geld verkauft wurden. Und am Ende ist das ein Transfer plus von, da sind jetzt immer, die Zahlen sind so und so, ich hab jetzt einen Transfermarkt genommen, einen Transfer plus von 20 Millionen Euro erzielt.
Ja, genau. Ich glaub bei den Kollegen in der Bild-Zeitung haben sie ihn den 50 Millionen Mann genannt, wenn man so alles zusammenrechnet, was er in seiner Zeit so eingenommen hat für den ersten FC Nürnberg. Man muss immer auch sehen, dass da sehr viele Spieler dabei sind, die überhaupt nicht funktioniert haben. Florian Pick kam vor der Saison aus Heidenheim und ist jetzt schon wieder weiter nach Münster gezogen und sowas. Zum Verhängnis geworden ist ihm auch ein bisschen dieser Systemwechsel tatsächlich. Er hat für eine defensive Viererkette eingekauft und mit zwei schnellen Außenspielern in der Offensive und sowas. Und die Positionen gab es dann gar nicht mehr. Stattdessen hat man Innenverteidiger gebraucht in dem plötzlich erfolgreichen System. Also es war wirklich nicht alles rund, aber man dachte, okay, so mit Joti XC Alexiou zusammen, der vielleicht das Scouting ein bisschen moderner macht, könnte das funktionieren und es wirkte dann so, Was ist dann passiert? Es wirkte ein bisschen so, als sei Olaf Rebbe diese Millionen ein bisschen zu Kopf gestiegen. Also das ist vorsichtig formuliert. Man hört es auch aus dem Verein, dass er nach der Transferphase, sodass einige im Umfeld der Mannschaft schon den Eindruck bekommen hatten, er provoziert irgendwie seinen Rauswurf und er fühlt sich in Nürnberg einfach nicht ausreichend gewürdigt in seiner Arbeit. Und ich hab dann am Ende der Transferphase einen Text über ihn geschrieben, den man auf nn.de nachlesen kann, wo ich ihn nicht Diamantenauge genannt hab, weil eben einfach zu viele falsche Einkäufe auch dabei waren. Aber Millionenauge, weil er gut verkaufen kann.
Selbst das war nicht genug?
Selbst das war nicht genug. Auf diesen Text hat er mich dann nach dem Auswärtsspiel in Magdeburg sehr emotional, würde ich mal sagen, angesprochen.
Gib uns jetzt die heißen Details, der Rasenfunk muss nachhören.
Genau, Details verrate ich lieber nicht, aber es stellte sich unter anderem in dem Gespräch dann noch heraus, dass er den Text gar nicht gelesen hatte, über den er sich da...
Moment, das ist eine gute Schule. Das hat Paldada vorgemacht mit Kicker-Reporter Steffen Rohr, den er ja auch für seinen Text kritisiert hat und man festgestellt hat, also entweder hast du den nicht gelesen oder nicht verstanden, weil das, was du ihm gerade vorwurst, hat er nicht geschrieben.
Ja, genau. Also das war bei uns ein bisschen ähnlich, war eine unschöne Auseinandersetzung, war nicht der Grund dafür, dass Olaf Rebbe jetzt nicht mehr in Nürnberg ist, auch wenn es dieses Gerücht hier in Nürnberg auch mal ein paar Tage lang gab. Es muss dann in Magdeburg auch noch mit einem anderen Verantwortlichen des Klubs ähnlich.
Vielleicht ist es dann auch die Summe vieler Teile.
Genau, ähnlich zugegangen sein und deshalb hat dann der Sportvorstand mehr oder weniger in Magdeburg beschlossen, dass das so nicht weiter geht. Auch da wird keine richtige Begründung genannt, nur inoffizielle. Es scheint die Zusammenarbeit auch aufgrund menschlicher Differenzen, vielleicht kann man so sagen, nicht mehr ganz funktioniert zu haben. Und man begründet es dann mit unterschiedlichen Ansichten über die zukünftige Ausrichtung. Aber es ist weniger überraschend, wer sich mit dem 1. FC Nürnberg auseinandersetzt, dass Olaf Rebbe nicht mehr jetzt für den 1. FC Nürnberg arbeitet, als es vielleicht im Rest des Fußballlandes erscheinen mag, wo sich alle denken, 1. FC Nürnberg macht, 1. FC Nürnberg Sachen. Und es wurde auch erstaunlich entspannt. Also es gab natürlich ein bisschen Aufregung rund um den Verein, aber ansonsten wurde das erstaunlich entspannt hingenommen, weil es, wie gesagt, ausreichend Menschen gibt, die dann noch ein bisschen das größere Ding im Blick haben und sehen, dass auch bei Olaf Rebbe's Transfer jetzt nicht nur die ganz geilen Sachen dabei waren.
Okay, das wäre nämlich noch eine Frage gewesen, wie schwer diese Trennung dann den Clubpersonel trifft. Dennis, du meldest dich hier ganz vorwärtlich. Ich schieß gerne rein.
Ja, ich hätte mal eine Frage an Fadi, die mich so ein bisschen umtreibt. Ich weiß damals, als der Transfer von Finn Yeltsch bekannt wurde und dann durchsickerte so acht bis zehn Millionen für einen 18-jährigen Zweitleger Spieler, da sind bei uns in der internen Chatgruppe die Emotionen sehr hochgekocht. Ist Finn Yeltsch dieses Geld wert? Also ist er ein Spieler, wo man sagt, der wird mal irgendwann 20, 30, 40 Millionen wert sein? Ist das jetzt ein gutes Invest von Stuttgarter Prof. B.s. oder ist das wieder so eine Alex Verle, haut das Geld raus, Aktion?
Es gibt solche Stimmen und solche Stimmen in Nürnberg. Ich möchte noch mal an meine Kloseeinschätzung vom September erinnern. Also es ist mit Vorsicht zu genießen, aber ich bin tatsächlich anders als manche meiner Kollegen, sehr überzeugt davon, dass Finn Yeltsch irgendwann nochmal, auch das ist wieder ein bisschen zynisch, wenn man dann sagt, er wird ein bisschen mehr wert sein, aber er wird auf jeden Fall ein Erstligaspieler beim VfB Stuttgart werden können. Also er ist für sein Alter wirklich enorm reif, hat natürlich noch Fehler drin, ist ein auch durchaus offensiv starker Innenverteidiger. Das war jetzt in der letzten Zeit in Nürnberg auch immer so, dass die Innenverteidiger immer mal wieder auch im defensiven Mittelfeld im Spielaufbau aufgetaucht sind und so was. Also ja, ich glaube, lohnt sich für den VfB. Ich bin mir angehört zu haben, für den Sommer war der Transfer abgemacht, dann hat der VfB ja einen Innenverteidiger verkauft und dann wollten sie Finjelcz. Jetzt schon haben hat es für den ersten FC Nürnberg noch mal ein bisschen finanziell einträglicher gemacht, aber ja, ich bin überzeugt von Finjelcz. Bei mir, selbst meine Podcast-Kollegen sind da nicht ganz der Meinung zumindest einer, aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, guter deutscher Innenverteidiger wird es.
Das glaube ich auch tatsächlich. Aus der Ferne beobachtet habe ich das Gefühl, einige Szenen gesehen zu haben. Die sind schon außerordentlich gut. Jetzt haben wir ausgemacht. Datenbasiertes Scouting, sehr gutes Verhandlungsgeschick. Das sind so zwei Komponenten des, ich sag mal, Ausbildungserfolgs des ersten FC Nürnberg in der jüngsten Zeit. Eine weitere Komponente ist ja aber auch die Akademie. Also wir haben Finjelic, wir haben Gian Oso, Nathaniel Brown. Und jetzt gehen diese Saison ja auch Talente, neuen oder den neuen Entwicklungsschritt. So Leute wie Jan Reichardt, Nick Seidel, Tim Janisch, Dustin Forkel kommen so langsam in den Profikader gerutscht. Wer ist in der Akademie dafür verantwortlich zu machen? Denn jahrelang hatte man das Gefühl, Nürnberg hochgeschätzte Akademie, aber groß rauskommt, tun sie dann woanders. Das hat sich jetzt so ein bisschen gedreht. Wie habe ich das Gefühl?
Ja, also man muss es auch das ein bisschen differenzieren. Ich glaube, Michael Wiesinger leitet das Nachwuchsleistungszentrum. So heißt das hier in Nürnberg noch, bild ich mir zumindest ein. Da war vor kurzem mal ein Namenswettbewerb. Weiß ich nicht genau, ob der Name jetzt schon offiziell ist, aber egal. Michael Wiesinger leitet das. Ich glaube, er leitet es gut. Man muss aber differenzieren. Jeanne Ouson, Brown, Yeltsch, das waren jetzt drei absolute Ausnahmetalente, bei denen ich mir nicht so sicher bin, wie viel der Verein da jetzt wirklich dafür kann, dass die da sind oder.
Die brechen einfach durch, weil sie so gut sind.
Ja, exakt. Und bei denen, die du jetzt sonst noch genannt hast, Seidel, Joachim, Jan Reichardt ist ein solider Zweitligatorwart momentan, spielt so seine erste Saison jetzt bei den Profis und so was. Da muss man erst mal abwarten, ob da jetzt dann ähnliche Entwicklungssprünge. Bin ich eher skeptisch. Ich glaube, das waren jetzt wirklich mal drei Spieler, bei denen man das große Glück hatte. Die kommen jetzt gerade retten dir ein bisschen die Finanzen, retten dir natürlich auch für eine oder zwei Saisons dein Spiel ein bisschen, den sportlichen zumindest verhindern sie den ganz großen sportlichen Misserfolg. Ob das jetzt so weitergeht, bezweifle ich momentan noch. Was glaube ich schon so ist, ist, dass Nürnberg für junge Spieler anderer Vereine ein bisschen attraktiver geworden ist. Das passiert dann immer so, wenn mal ein Verein zwei, drei Spieler gut verkauft hat oder nach oben gebracht hat, dann erzählen da immer an allen Standorten die Leute, ja das war vor kurzem noch irgendwie so die Erzählung in Fürth. Wir sind der Ausbildungsverein Nummer eins und die Leute bieten uns alles an, was irgendwie Talent besitzt und so was. Das ist vielleicht, da hat auch Jens Kastrup tatsächlich, um auf den nochmal zurückzukommen, auch eine Rolle gespielt, weil der einfach in Nürnberg eine gute Entwicklung genommen hat. Aber ob das in Nürnberg so weitergeht, da wage ich noch zu bezweifeln, dass da jetzt ständig irgendeiner rauskommt aus der Jugend, der dann ein Jahr später für 10 Millionen irgendwo verkauft wird.
Verstehe. So und welche Bedeutung hat das jetzt alles für die allgemeine wirtschaftliche Lage des Vereins? Wie ist Nürnberg derzeit aufgestellt? Weil man weiß, Nürnberg einer dieser chronisch klammen Clubs, aber trotzdem kann man da ja mal ein bisschen differenzieren, wie sich das in den letzten Jahren entwickelt hat. Und gibt es beispielsweise infrastrukturelle Projekte, die Geld brauchen? Also steht da auch irgendwas an in nächster Zeit?
Nürnberg ist immer noch ein finanziell klammer Club, auch wenn Reppe und KC. Alexiou, als sie uns nach der Transferphase dann mal zum Gespräch eingeladen haben, um ihrem Stolz-Ausdruck zu verleihen, gesagt haben, dass sie zumindest jetzt nicht unbedingt verkaufen müssen nach den Einnahmen, die sie da jetzt generiert haben. Aber der Club...
Das sagt man natürlich auch gerne, das treibt ja die Preise auch hoch.
Exakt, so ist es. Und da geht es tatsächlich in erster Linie, glaube ich, jetzt um Caspar Jander, den der 1. FC Nürnberg wahrscheinlich eher nicht für 6 Millionen Euro ziehen lassen würde im nächsten Sommer, sondern dann schon in die Yeltsch-Dimensionen rein gehen wollen würde. Ansonsten ist der 1. FC Nürnberg nach wie vor arm. Das ist einfach zu lange zweite Liga jetzt. Zu oft falsche Entscheidungen von Hacking und Treppe, auch auf dem Transfermarkt, wird dann immer ein bisschen so behauptet, das fehlende Geld liege daran, dass man einfach einen zu großen Verwaltungsapparat aufgebaut hat oder auch beibehalten hat in der zweiten Liga, weil man sich immer noch als Erstligis gefühlt hat. Ich glaube, das ist das geringere Problem verglichen mit all diesen vollkommen danebengegangenen Spielzeiten zuletzt und auch Transfers und sowas. Es ist geplant, ein neues Stadion zu bauen.
Wie weit ist man da?
Max Morlock-Stadion ist tatsächlich in die Jahre gekommen. Man fühlte sich sehr weit. So gefühlt hat es sich an, hörte es sich an, es würden mehr oder weniger morgen die Bagger kommen.
Ist das nicht immer so? Das war in Berlin ganz genauso.
Bis dann vor kurzem eine Agentur noch mal die Pläne ein bisschen nachgerechnet hat und dann feststellen musste, dass in der einen Kalkulation des 1. FC Nürnberg knapp 100 Millionen Euro fehlen würden und der Klub dann 20 Millionen oder noch ein bisschen mehr Pacht im Jahr zahlen müsste. Also das hat das ganze Projekt jetzt ein bisschen ausgebremst, sowohl bei der Stadt als auch beim 1. FC Nürnberg. Ist man jetzt sehr bemüht, die Menschen davon zu überzeugen, dass es trotzdem zeitnah weitergeht, aber wohl mit einer etwas abgespeckten Version.
Zwei Fragen dazu. Erstes Thema Standort und zweite Frage Finanzierung. Das sind ja immer so auch die zwei großen Fragen. Also weiß man, wo es stehen soll? Was passiert mit dem alten Stadion und wie finanziert man das?
Es soll es wird ein Vollumbau. Also steht da, wo jetzt das Max-Morlock-Stadion steht. Und Finanzierung war immer so 30 Millionen, soll der 1. FC Nürnberg beisteuern, wie auch immer. Und 30 Millionen die Stadt und der Rest eben über Investoren und Sonstiges. Ich war immer schon ein bisschen skeptisch. Wir alle wissen, wie schwierig es derzeit ist zu bauen und dann so ein Projekt hinzustellen. Der 1. FC Nürnberg zahlt tatsächlich oder die Stadt zahlt tatsächlich sehr viel, um das Max-Morlock-Stadion, das einigermaßen marode ist, in Stand zu halten. Das war so auch das Argument in der Stadt, im Stadtrat immer, dass das Geld kann man sich auch sparen und dann baut man eben gleich ein neues Stadion. Es ist sehr spannend, wie es da weitergeht. Es war dann immer vom 50.000 Zuschauerinnen-Stadion die Rede, jetzt gibt es wieder welche, die sich auch plus 40.000 vorstellen können. Es sollte ein Hotel integriert werden, auch das ist jetzt wohl eher mal erst mal wieder gestrichen, nachdem man diese kleine Finanzlücke entdeckt hat. Bleibt spannend, wird tatsächlich in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten ein Thema bleiben, rund um den 1. FC Nürnberg. Meine Skepsis ist nach wie vor da, wie das funktionieren soll. Aber was man immer so hört, ist es muss funktionieren und mal gucken.
Man kennt ja viele Vereine, die sich an so einem Stadion-Projekt völlig verhoben haben. Deswegen sollte man ja wirklich vier und fünf Mal drüber rechnen.
Ja, exakt.
Zurück ins Hier und Jetzt. Nürnberg steht derzeit auf Rang 9, fünf Punkte hinter Platz 3 und 2. Schielt man jetzt auf den Aufstieg? Wohin soll der und wohin soll der Klub mittelfristig sich entwickeln? Wie ist da die Kommunikation der Verantwortlichen, sowohl von Klose als auch dann eben den höher liegenden Gremien?
Erst mal die höher liegenden. Es war ja war der Plan, in Nürnberg eine ruhige Saison zu spielen.
Das ist ja schon mal hybris in Nürnberg.
Exakt. Hat man einerseits geschafft mit Platz 9 irgendwie, aber andererseits den Sportdirektor rausschmeißen nach der erfolgreichsten Transferphase. Das ist der Vereinsgeschichte spricht dann wiederum, spricht wiederum dagegen. Wir hatten schon eine Trainerdiskussion, eine Torwartdiskussion in Nürnberg. Es gibt gerade mit Mai hier im Relien Spieler im Sommer erst gekommen. Ein Angreifer aus Aserbaidschan, der jetzt gerne schnell wieder weg will und so was. Miroslav Klose hat am Sonntag tatsächlich nach dem Spiel gegen Ulm gesagt, dass seine Mannschaft auf dem Weg zu einer Spitzenmannschaft ist. Alle anderen bleiben da noch zurückhaltend. Wer den 1. FC Nürnberg ein bisschen kennt, der weiß, das Umfeld, das von Olaf Reppel kürzlich mal als das schwierige Umfeld bezeichnet worden ist.
Klassiker?
Sieht sechs Punkte Rückstand auf den 1. FC Köln und ist davon überzeugt, dass es in drei Spieltagen spätestens, dass der 1. FC Köln dann überholt ist. Also die Euphorie wird gerade ein bisschen größer. Hängt sehr viel vom Spiel gegen die Hertha am Wochenende, am Freitag ab. Tatsächlich sieht man aber auch, man hat jetzt fünf der letzten sechs Spiele gewonnen, es ist immer noch erst neunter, könnte schwierig werden, dann nochmal ganz oben ranzukommen. Und das wäre dann tatsächlich, damit werden dann auch alle rund um den Verein einigermaßen fein.
Und mittelfristig, wie plant der Club? Also es gibt ja immer dieses typische, wir wollen zu den Top 25 Deutschlands herauf.
Ich wollte sagen, ja auch wir auf der 1. FC Nürnberg will zu den Top 25 in Deutschland. Was ich auch wirklich für eine riesen Quatschansage halte, aber tatsächlich ist es genauso von den Verantwortlichen kürzlich erst wieder gefallen. Ja, der 1. FC Nürnberg muss irgendwann wieder in die 1. Liga aufsteigen aus finanzieller Not. Ganz einfach, ob das gelingen kann. Diese Saison macht ein bisschen mehr Hoffnung, aber da gab es auch in der Vergangenheit immer mal wieder so eine Spielzeit, wo man dachte, okay, das ist auf einem guten Weg und in der nächsten wird dann alles wieder zerschmettert. Man muss mal gucken, Joti Hacielic Sioux ist jetzt in seinem ersten Jahr Sportvorstand, war vorher wirklich nur in der Verbandsarbeit tätig, kann man noch nicht so ganz einschätzen, wie der arbeitet. Es hört sich immer alles ganz gut an. Man muss mal gucken, wie es jetzt ist, wenn er dann mal für eine Transferphase wirklich allein verantwortlich ist oder mit demjenigen oder derjenigen Nachfolgerin von Olaf Reppe dann vielleicht.
Vielleicht. Wir werden das mit Spannung verfolgen. Dementsprechend bleibt mir eigentlich nur noch zu sagen, vielen lieben Dank Dennis, vielen lieben Dank Fadi, dass ihr eure Vereine hier einmal komplett ausgeführt habt. Man könnte noch ewig weiterreden, glaube ich. Also sowohl Köln als auch Nürnberg bieten Stoff ohne Ende. Aber vielleicht kommt es in dieser Saison nochmal dazu. Wenn beide oben groß angreifen, dann kommen wir in der Ligatur gar nicht dran vorbei. Bis dahin spiele ich hier schon mal das Intro ab. Das läuft ja immer schon eine Weile und möchte an dieser Stelle dann noch sagen, dass ich natürlich darauf hinweisen möchte, dass ihr supporter und supporterin werden könnt. Dieses wunderbare Podcast geht dafür auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Podcasts habe ich dieses Mal keine zu empfehlen, aber wie gesagt, Fadi, Dennis, vielen lieben Dank und dann einfach bis zum nächsten Mal. Ich freue mich drauf.
Tschüss.
Der Rasenfunk hebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank.